let's talk about the news and i got to
say um
we got the story from tipgus.com
criminal case against epstein's prison
guards dropped on thursday just one day
after gizlane maxwell is convicted of
sex trafficking the charges against
epstein's prison guards are dropped now
yesterday my friends i pointed out after
reading the headline that we would be
demonetized because when a story is this
big and this important there's no point
in trying to dance around it we will be
demonetized and then of course i threw
it over to luke and luke just went off
and so we'll we'll carry on with that
new tradition
luke this criminal cover-up is reaching
its epidemic to the point where it's
epidemic what i don't know what i'm
trying to say here
are you freaking kidding me like the
guards the guards that were sleeping
falsifying records the people that were
responsible for the the
i can't say that
oh my gosh luke for the extermination oh
let's just let's just say jeffrey
epstein
was left alone in his cell by sleeping
guards and then later was found not
alive anymore yes
[Laughter]
whatever you may call it some people
like to name it a part of someone who
was running as a presidential candidate
but that's another thing but these
guards were caught napping they were
caught allegedly looking up the news
they were caught looking
for motorcycles and furniture and other
expensive items where they were doing
well they falsified the records here and
there were the ones that were supposed
to be doing the rounds checking on
epstein making sure that of course he
did not hurt himself in any way shape or
form and of course they absolutely
failed on that job what happened to
epstein no one knows the video footage
of his first alleged attempt to hurt
himself was literally
destroyed and not found under the hands
of the authorities that of course later
came out with the statement by james
comey's daughter and said oh no we just
we just lost the tapes we don't know
what happened there was of course a
second attempt attempt whatever may
happen we don't know because again these
guards were allegedly too busy looking
to buy motorcycles to find out so again
the the evidence here is being once
again destroyed and the fact that these
guards had their charges dropped by the
federal government shows you just how
complicit how disgusting how rotten this
system is and how they want you to
forget this very important story the
story of the decade when the mainstream
media was promoting jeffrey epstein
as some kind of great philanthropist
they were promoting him as some kind of
big money guy a wall street guy a hedge
fund guy everyone including even miss
mccain knew that he was up to extremely
awful horrible things and everyone
within the government knew what he was
doing the fbi knew since the 90s and
they were sitting on their hands as
thousands of children were being hurt
and literally sacrificed at the altar
for the ruling elites to do whatever
they wanted to in horrible disgusting
ways and i got a lot more to say about
this than princess connected to this but
you've got to say something to me i got
to say something very important for
everybody who's listening to this
segment
the reason this story is dropping just
before new year's eve viewership is
going to be down across the board
ratings are going to be down everyone's
on vacation no one's paying attention
they are covering this up they sealed
the records the trial was rushed through
we got a glimpse through a keyhole there
was more evidence the fbi had and
apparently was cataloged that's never
gone been gone through and now they're
saying with the records being resealed
all of these high-profile individuals
who are flying on this plane never going
to find out about it they drop the trial
that the conviction comes just after
christmas
they're dropping the criminal charges
against the guards in the prison where
epstein
lost his life
and it's happening on during a holiday
it it is it is you do this this is this
is a pr
dead zone okay companies release
information the news comes out on friday
nights or during holidays to make sure
no one sees it
now i don't have all the answers this is
a
but but people you need to make sure
that people hear this story because as
big as it was when we heard epstein was
no longer alive in his prison cell this
story the story the guards are having
their charges drop needs to be just as
big and we're fighting a a massive
30-foot wall from sea to shining sea
keeping this information out and that is
releasing it on a holiday this is
absolutely a criminal cover-up and
nothing else what else can you can you
say here why did the government say hey
these people that are responsible for
thousands of children never getting
justice these guards that are
responsible for these men that hurt
children in unspeakable ways never
facing justice these guards are the ones
responsible for it they have so much
weighing on their decisions that night
and they're not going to be held
responsible for one of the biggest
injustices in our legal justice system i
mean epstein was in the hands of the
authorities they had everything he would
have spoken he would have leaked names
he had the profiles he had the dvds he
had the cds he had the hard drives on so
many prominent individuals that of
course he surveilled he had so much
blackmail so much power so much truth
and the federal government is squashing
it making sure you will never see it and
that is utterly disgusting because your
tax dollars your ignorance literally
allowed some of the worst human
atrocities to happen on the face of this
earth that were sanctioned stamped on by
the approval of the federal authorities
by the police officers the prosecutors
the judges the politicians the
regulators all of them were involved
here and this system is rotten to its
core and to see this major story break
now on on a thursday right before new
year's this is deliberate this didn't
happen today by the way people need to
understand this happened some unknown
time ago and now we're finding out about
it it's absolutely crazy oh do you want
to see that well the thing that i think
about in issues like this is why has
society become so apathetic what is it i
mean oh this is a little bit you know
tangential but like what is it in our
food system that makes us so apathetic
towards this what is it about our
day-to-day
boring drive to work that makes us so
apathetic sugar and yeah
and like
what is it about the you know the this
over stimulation that we see in society
that makes us not care about this so and
then from that standpoint if you can
kind of pull out a little bit what could
the average person even do let's say
that this head broken during a peak news
cycle what could the average person even
do about it to where they're not so
demoralized that they just sit there and
go i don't know what do you want me to
do and then they just get back to the to
the bread and circus you know i was just
thinking we should do a skit like the
movie don't look up so in the movie you
know i guess spoiler alert it's not that
big of a spoiler because if you know if
you read what the movie's about it's
just people saying like there's a
there's a meteor a comet gonna hit the
earth and they go on they go on tv and
the people on tv are like uh-huh i think
they would be it would be fascinating to
have a similar sketch where it's like
luke goes on a talk show and he's like
powerful global elites are flying on
these planes including the former
president to two former presidents
you've got the one of the wealthiest men
in the world there are children being
trafficked and they're like that's so
crazy
how can i get one of these flights
i think that has just happened right
you know yeah no no no that's a that's
an excellent idea even for a funny skit
video instead of the asteroid coming to
destroy earth it's a whole bunch of like
hopped up billionaires that are ready to
like do horrible things it's just
children and there's an epidemic of them
going wild literally having their way
and doing unspeakable and hurting
children like 50 bill gates marching
through the streets
bill gates gets a mutation device where
he
replicates and there's thousands of them
and they're all going on and like like a
pandemic of the zombies but instead of
zombies they do other unspeakable things
especially little children and then
there's no future and then we can make
this like a no future because there's no
more children because the bill gates and
the other horrible people have their
ways with them but there's also a lot of
other important details here that we got
to talk about with prince andrew i'll
say one more thing and i'll throw it to
you on prince andrew i want to let
people know that when luke wakes up in
the morning well i shouldn't say in the
morning when luke wakes up just around
the crack of noon yeah and he's very
groggy and tired and i'm like i gotta
get sky whipped into shape there's
actually one magic word i can say to
make it so that luke instantly is in 110
he's like walking around he's in his
pajamas he's like i'm tired man you got
any coffee and i go epstein
and then he just goes off and he's 100
i'm like he's ready
this is pretty important what you just
said there so if you when you study
spiritual growth just books like uh
power okay power versus force um that
you can look up and they talk about how
one of the lowest levels in human
consciousness is apathy right and the
next level above that is anger and so in
many ways i think the mainstream media
plays into that where if somebody's in
an apathetic mode and then you put a
story about love or peace or joy or fun
that doesn't resonate what energizes us
in like in my little thing that i do i
call it a derp state basically this
apathetic derpy state that most of us
are in and they will have to fight our
way out of
um what happens is that the media knows
that makes people angry and so we're
kind of stuck in this thing where
it's hard to get people to that next
level right so in spiritual growth you
know if you've ever read eckhart tolle
he calls the second book is called a new
earth you know and a lot of people talk
about that like what would a better
world
actually look like and when most of us
are eating the wrong foods and we're
spaced out and we're in apathy and then
you hear about jeffrey epstein i mean
let's be like i loved your point you
said tim and i took a huge amount of
knowledge from that but then i honestly
do wonder even if that had been posted
on a major news day would anything have
even happened i mean it is so much in
your face i'm probably more widow well
well i'll say this man i think it was a
big red pill moment for a lot of
americans yes when the dude was no
longer alive in his prison cell we'll
just we'll say it that way because
no he was just he was just he was there
and then all of a sudden he was no
longer alive whatever you want whatever
you want to say about it the point is
a lot of people were just like whoa
and so that may not have a direct effect
on will they go outside and protest but
it'll probably have a big impact on what
they read in the news and could shift
culture very very much so i like to say
taken out because there's many
interpretations where you could kind of
allude to what happened here but this is
a key linchpin story that that has a lot
of people's confidence in the entire
system hanging in the balance because
people understand if your system if your
tax dollars if your police officers your
judges your prosecutors are literally
out there participating aiding and
abetting or looking the other way as
children or being hurt in unspeakable
ways that's a system that does not have
any trust within it and this is why the
when this story broke there was a huge
response to this not by the corporate
media not even by the big tech social
media people had to force the hashtag
jeffreyepstein didn't
blank himself that hashtag went almost
everywhere corporate media was forced to
cover it and and the the kind of veil
surrounding this entire system started
to unfold because people started to see
how peop how things really work in
washington dc you know that bill that's
very popular populist policies that
never get passed why don't they get
passed what power do these special
interests have what extortion abilities
what blackmail do they have for these
politicians to always turn their back on
the citizens and never delivered on
their promises well we got a sneak peek
at it we got a small window we got the
tip of the iceberg with jeffrey epstein
and the rabbit hole goes a lot deeper uh
now so what can the average person do
about this their attention their energy
just even understanding this is
extremely powerful because the system
can't function if if not enough people
believe in them okay so
no no i was just going to say that like
that that's something that's really
bothering me too that's this you keep
iterating the same question i keep
thinking it's just like okay so what can
you do what can the average person do
yes being red pilled on this whole
story is pretty important but maybe at
some level it would help people feel
like they could um sort of
if they see this on the national level
and they see how deep it is and how
corrosive the whole system can be and
with an issue like this then maybe it
would make them think well i can't let
this happen at the local level you know
i mean if
because like they can't do anything
about manhattan if they're in some in
the midwest somewhere but they could be
aware of wow if it could happen there
then it can happen here and they're
going to do whatever they can to get
engaged in local politics and local
school school boards and figure out ways
to make sure that there's accountability
when bad stuff happens it's it's not
just about voting it's not just about
getting involved or anything like that
if one day let's just put this away
let's say tomorrow we woke up and
literally every single person in this
country was actively against critical
race practice in schools it would be
gone because all of a sudden even
democrats would be like we are going to
lose because people are so strongly
against this
everybody who heard that story about
these prison guards and immediately
regular people who are not in politics
were like yo what the just happened
that's a moment where people might just
say very simply i'm not going to put
money towards certain things i'm going
to read different news sources it can
cause such a major cultural shift that
i think an important point that luke
brought up is confidence in a system is
the only way the system can function
so if one day everybody woke up and felt
that the us dollar had no value it would
literally have no value so when people
get this news it changes their
perception it can strip confidence away
from the system that's why they put it
out just before new year's eve when
nobody's paying attention and if the
government cared about you or your
children or just innocent children at
all they would have went to these guards
and they would have said okay what
happened here did you really just fall
asleep were you really buying furniture
here were you buying a motorcycle here
or did something else happen we're gonna
put pressure on you you're gonna face a
very stiff sentence for this dereliction
of duty because you just created
injustice for thousands of children they
didn't do any of that they just
mysteriously someday before this dropped
the charges when did they drop the
charges we don't know because again a
lot of this as tim is saying was
specifically scheduled in a way so not
enough people know about this they're
afraid of more people finding out about
this and this is why if the feds really
cared about you they would have went to
maxwell and and they would have been
like okay you were the procurer who did
you procure who too who else was in this
who else was involved here who else were
you hanging out here tell us and we'll
give you a lesser sentence one of those
individuals admittedly is the man who
doesn't sweat at all doesn't have any
sweat glands according to him is of
course mr prince andrew the queen's son
of the queen's and and the royal family
have a lot of connections to really
awful people who do very similar things
that epstein did by the way epstein is
not the first person connected to the
royal family that does these awful
horrible things
real quick there's a picture of epstein
and maxwell at the queen's cottage
there's a picture of kevin spacey and
galen maxwell sitting on the throne
are you kidding me how many of these
people are interconnected
the way that i think about it when
you're in a business basically the way
most businesses function is you keep
gradually increasing the price and then
what you do is you tend to shrink what
it is that you're giving and then you
wait until customers stop buying right
so there was freedoms that were won for
us by people largely in the past and
what happened is is that the
establishment can begin to infringe on
those freedoms or even flaunt this
nonsense in our face
and as long as there's no boundary
that will keep going right because if
you're in a business and then you just
keep raising the price raising the price
certainly you're like they're just going
to let us keep raising the price they
say you sell orange juice you keep
giving less and less orange juice the
point is like one drop
right and then you're like they're gonna
buy a drop for a hundred dollars well do
it for do it for a thousand dollars then
and so what's happening is that back in
the day when the kind of people lived in
our society who would have had some kind
of a boundary they can't just push the
envelope like they have in 2020 like
they have with epson all this different
kind of stuff but i look at myself so
you know me and luke are friends and
i've been listening to what he's saying
for years tim i've watched what you're
saying for years and i'm like i was like
okay i'm sold what do i do right and
it's like i don't know what to do so
talk to people
and i and i do and i make videos about
it and i have a new video series about
it and all that kind of stuff but i just
like when i'm teaching a seminar for
example in personal growth what we try
to do is get people to buy into this
idea that they should improve and then
we give them a direction on what to do
for somebody who so for me watching this
it's like what me watching a seminar
with this incredible theory
but what do you do so i love telling
people about it yeah you tell more
people about it because
like i i think confidence in a system is
the most important thing taking it away
if if people aren't paying attention and
don't care the criminals get away with
it but if you uh uh if you've got if you
got 100 people and they all have their
backs turned to a bank the bank robber's
like now's my chance if you tell hey
everybody turn around and they all do
the guy's gonna be like i'm gonna i'm
not gonna do this everybody's watching
now yeah i mean that's one way to put it
once everyone's paying attention it
makes it very difficult for criminals to
get away with this stuff it's because
people get mad people vote people don't
buy things it breaks confidence in the
system if every single person in this
country was focused on this story right
now and believed something wrong was
happening the politicians would be
sweating bullets they could only get
away with it if people are not paying
attention to what they're doing with
that attention it is leading to some
circumstances glenn maxwell awful person
according to all her accusers is going
away jeffrey epstein no longer here if
we were totally blind to this entire
situation that operation would have been
going on vh vh1 was making documentary
pieces about how great epstein was how
much money he had and people were
falling for that trap and there was
people coming to him with their children
be like yeah you're cool we want to hang
out not knowing that this is a big
monster that will hurt you the the more
we know about these monsters there's a
reason bill gates spends hundreds of
millions of dollars buying off the
corporate media literally he sent i
think 319 million dollars all over the
corporate media he does that because
without people's ignorance he can't get
away with a lot of the stuff that he's
doing and he's rarely ever he was asked
i think once or twice about his
connection to of course jeffrey epstein
there's a far bigger extensive uh
connection here his response to it was
atrocious his response to it was even
more surprising that even the question
being asked the first time but but again
this story doesn't end and i just before
rihanna i want to talk about prince
andrew because this also is the breaking
of the dam of this entire establishment
system that is so uh
disgusting and has so much blackmail in
it because andrew's lawyers are now
holding emergency talks there's the the
victims defense lawyer who said that
andrew should be shaking in his boots he
just filed a motion to make sure that
all of the witness testimony including
his depot decision is kept secret from
the general public this has never been
heard from before he's facing a civil
suit uh in the united states he's making
a lot of outlandish arguments we're
still waiting for him to be deposed and
when he's deposed he's going to be
sitting there in front of the lawyers
representing the victims the children
here that were hurt here and he's going
to have to answer some serious questions
and there's a lot of them including how
the royal protection officers literally
destroyed evidence to his alibi there is
a lot of dirty disgusting things
happening here and it's only our ability
to talk about it get it out there that
is able to stop a lot of this in its
tracks and it did work in some way it's
it's hard to it's hard to move on from
the story because i'm really quite
offended that they're putting it out
right now and it's obvious why that's
why i've brought it up so much so so
please guys if you're hearing this keep
this fresh in your mind keep keep a tab
open in your browser with the story and
get ready to share it in the next week
or so to let people know you got to pay
attention to this stuff because these
are these are evil people doing evil
things but one last thing one last thing
i'm sorry i just have a million things i
want to say but i just really quickly
this also bridges the gap between the
left and the right people on the left
agree people on the right agree what
happened here in this specific instant
is an absolute horrible case of
government out of control that is
absolutely unaccountable this is a
potential item that could bring us all
together against that powers that be
that truly do run things and truly make
things miserable for us and it shatters
that divide and conquer agenda that's
why i talk about this so much and i get
so passionate about it because it's so
important let me let me give a shout out
to hassan [ __ ] he's got a tweet hassan
us hassan the hun
i responded with eight fire emojis he
said my thoughts are with the clinton
family in this trying time as their
close and personal best friend pictured
front and center at chelsea clinton's
wedding is going to federal prison for
sex trafficking minors
and according to one report i saw i
haven't fact checked this one apparently
the wedding was like invite only no
strangers allowed so
yeah
yeah this this this does bring the left
and the right together very much so
and there's there's a viral tweet that a
tweet that went viral it was posted all
over reddit and someone said if joe
biden was involved with epstein then he
should go to prison if donald trump was
involved with epstein he should go to
prison see was that so hard and i'm like
no it wasn't because literally everyone
agrees the left so
there's people who are trying to make it
seem like trump supporters are like well
trump should get away with it
everybody agrees release the documents
show us the book show us everybody show
us the tapes i don't care if they're on
the left or the right
that's it all the more reason to bury it
exactly live week yeah
luke mentioned divide and conquer so
very much important for the for the
establishment
and this is the one thing that brings us
together and it scares the crap out of
the establishment it scares the crap out
of the corporate media they want this
story to go away this decision again i
have to say this again this decision
with the federal government dropping
these charges didn't happen today it
happened some other time we don't know
when it happened deliberately in a way
so we do not pay attention to it that's
and and when they're doing all this you
know it's showing that that their
propaganda is extremely important for
everything that they're doing and it
could be stopped with the truth thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time